Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir à tous.
Il y a de nombreuses raisons qui font que
je ne devrais pas me trouver sur scène.
Notamment parce que
je n’ai pas d’addiction particulière.
Mais c’est un phénomène très étrange,
surtout très éclairant
sur la nature humaine,
et donc c’est ça qui m’intéresse.
Ce qui est étrange dans l’addiction,
c’est que non seulement on agit
contre sa propre volonté,
mais aussi contre soi-même.
Je sais que je ne dois pas boire,
je décide de ne pas boire, je bois.
C’est étrange parce que
c’est comme si je disais :
« Il faudrait que j’ouvre ma main. »
Je décide d’ouvrir ma main
et à la place, je constate
que c’est mon pied qui se soulève.
Comment est-ce possible ?
L’addiction ne pose donc pas simplement
la question de la maîtrise de soi,
mais la question du soi.
Autrement dit : qui suis-je vraiment ?
Comment est-ce que je fonctionne ?
Dire que mon corps agit sans ma volonté,
ça peut paraître très bizarre,
mais en fait, quand on y réfléchit, c'est
comme ça que ça se passe tout le temps.
Si je pose ma main
sur une plaque chauffante brûlante,
je la retire immédiatement.
C’est un simple réflexe,
une réaction nerveuse,
ma volonté n’a pas agi.
Mais si je remarque que j’ai ma main
sur une plaque chauffante froide,
je la retire aussi immédiatement.
Ça n'a pas été un réflexe.
Ça n’a pas non plus dépendu
de ma volonté, de mon raisonnement.
Autre cas : je suis en colère.
Donc je crie, je m’agite, je hurle.
Après, généralement, je regrette.
Mais pendant cette phase de colère,
j’ai été hors de moi.
Mon raisonnement, ma volonté consciente,
n’ont hélas servi à rien.
Si je suis en voiture,
je pilote de manière automatique,
je peux faire des choses très compliquées,
discuter, écouter de la musique.
Tout se passe sans ma volonté.
Ce que je veux juste montrer avec ces
quelques exemples très, très simples,
c’est que la volonté consciente
n’est pas seule à diriger notre corps,
à diriger nos actions.
Nous avons plein d’autres systèmes
en parallèle
qui peuvent aussi agir sans la volonté.
Et on pourrait dire : « Heureusement ! »,
parce que tous ces chemins,
ces raccourcis, ces automatismes,
c’est ça qui nous permet de vivre
sans avoir à réfléchir 24 heures sur 24
et à prendre des décisions
à chaque seconde.
Cependant, il y a
une différence fondamentale
entre ces cas très simples
et le cas de l’addiction.
Parce que dans le cas de l’addiction,
ma volonté consciente est présente,
mon raisonnement fonctionne,
j’aboutis à une conclusion,
et ce qui se passe, c’est que je fais le
contraire de ce que je viens de décider.
On pourrait imaginer que
c’est une faiblesse de la volonté,
c’est-à-dire une lutte entre le désir
et la raison, le désir l’emportant.
Le plus probable, c’est que ce n’est pas
une faiblesse de la volonté,
mais un court-circuit de la volonté.
On l'a vu avec l'exemple de la voiture.
Quand j’apprends à conduire, bien sûr
que je suis attentif à chaque seconde,
attentif à tous les gestes que je fais,
attentif à tout ce qui
se passe autour de moi.
Mais petit à petit, avec l’expérience,
je me retrouve donc à construire
une sorte de pilote automatique.
Et donc, in fine, je lui délègue
la conduite de la voiture
et je peux faire autre chose.
En cas de danger, ma volonté consciente
reprend la main sur le corps
et donc le contrôle sur la voiture.
Ce qui se passe avec l’addiction,
c’est que probablement,
vous ne pouvez pas reprendre la main
sur le pilote automatique.
C’est-à-dire qu’en fait, votre volonté
consciente est court-circuitée.
Lorsque vous êtes face à l’action,
vous n’êtes pas sur la place du pilote,
vous êtes sur la place du passager.
Le passé, dans ce cas-là, n’a pas inscrit
simplement des chemins, des raccourcis,
pour vous permettre
de vous faciliter la vie.
Ça a créé une véritable autoroute
avec des barrières de sécurité
et une seule sortie bien déterminée.
Et donc, une fois que vous
êtes engagé là-dedans,
votre volonté consciente peut dire
tout ce qu’elle veut,
physiquement, vous suivez l’autoroute.
Cette autoroute aura des barrières de
sécurité qui seront d’autant plus hautes,
d’autant plus difficiles à éviter,
que le bénéfice perçu lors de
sa construction aura été important.
Ce bénéfice doit avoir bien sûr
été du plaisir intense,
mais aussi la suppression d’une douleur
trop lourde à porter.
Dans le cas de l’addiction, ce n’est pas
« Je décide quelque chose
et ensuite je fais le contraire. »
Ce qu’il se passe probablement,
c’est que j’ai inscrit en fait
dans mon cerveau la décision passée.
Je continue à faire
ce que j’ai décidé dans le passé
et qui a à l’époque été jugé bon,
mais qui, aujourd’hui, me court-circuite.
Répondre à la question
« Qui suis-je vraiment ? »
c’est donc en fait essayer de répondre
à la question suivante :
« Qu’est-ce que le passé a fait de moi ? »
Quels sont les chemins, les routes,
mais aussi les autoroutes
qui se sont inscrits en moi
et qui maintenant me dirigent ?
Prendre conscience de cette programmation,
c’est déjà essayer d’aller
vers un peu plus de liberté,
essayer de se donner la possibilité
d’aller vers d’autres ailleurs.
Mais bien sûr,
c’est extrêmement difficile.
Tout aussi difficile que d’essayer
d’éviter de retirer sa main
d’une plaque chauffante froide.
Et c’est d’autant plus difficile que
la plupart du temps, on se ment,
on se raconte des histoires
pour ne pas avoir à reconnaître
qu’on ne dirige pas grand-chose.
Ainsi, après avoir bu
un très grand nombre de verres,
je continue à me répéter :
« Allez encore un.
Après promis, j’arrête. »
Le marin veut croire et veut continuer à
croire que c'est lui qui dirige le bateau.
Je vous ai dit au début que
je n’avais pas d’addiction particulière,
ça ne veut pas dire pas de problèmes.
J’ai notamment un problème assez important
à titre personnel,
mais aussi professionnel, et qui est pour
moi quelque chose d'incompréhensible.
Dérèglement climatique,
dérèglement du cycle de l’eau,
destruction de la biodiversité,
épuisement des ressources, etc.
Nous allons droit à la catastrophe,
pourtant nous ne faisons rien.
C'est incompréhensible.
Bien sûr, je sais,
il y a des intérêts privés
qui bénéficient de cette situation
et donc ne veulent pas la changer.
À titre d’exemple, nous avons rencontré
un vice-président développement durable
d’un leader mondial industriel
qui nous a déclaré :
« Water is a collateral damage. »
« L’eau est un dommage collatéral. »
Autrement dit, je sais bien
que je détruis la planète,
mais ça me fait gagner de l’argent.
Bien sûr, je sais aussi qu’il y a
la soumission à l’autorité
qui peut transformer
les humains en moutons.
Moutons qui détruisent la planète, pas
pour y gagner quelque chose, par intérêt,
mais tout simplement parce
qu’on leur a demandé de le faire.
Mais malgré tout,
ça reste incompréhensible
parce que la plupart d’entre nous ne fait
pas partie de ces deux catégories.
Pourtant, nous restons dans l’immeuble
en feu et nous n’essayons pas d’en sortir.
C'est incompréhensible.
Nous savons que nous nous détruisons,
que nous agissons contre nous-mêmes.
Nous souhaitons ralentir a minima
cette course vers la catastrophe,
mais nous ne faisons rien.
Ça ne vous rappelle pas quelque chose ?
Peut-il y avoir des addictions sociales,
qui nous concernent tous,
qui aient créé des courts-circuits
dans notre cerveau
et qui nous empêchent
de sortir de l’immeuble en feu ?
La question posée par l’addiction
ne serait pas simplement donc
« Qui suis-je vraiment ? », mais
aussi « Qui sommes-nous vraiment ? »
Dans le cas d’addictions sociales,
quel serait le court-circuit
et comment aurait-il été construit ?
Mon hypothèse est l’addiction au confort,
aux petits plaisirs quotidiens,
l’addiction au fauteuil moelleux.
La société de consommation a transformé
nos vies en une suite de micro-plaisirs
qui ont construit autant de
micro-courts-circuits dans nos cerveaux,
dans nos cœurs et dans notre volonté.
Nous sommes maintenant programmés
pour consommer
et si nous ne cherchons pas
à nous déprogrammer,
il nous sera très, très difficile
de sortir de l’immeuble en feu.
Certains détruisent le monde par intérêt,
d'autres le détruisent par obéissance,
mais je pense que la plupart d’entre nous
le détruisons par habitude.
Et d’ailleurs, en français,
il est récent de parler d’addiction.
Le mot français, en fait,
c’est plutôt « assuétude »,
du latin « assuetudo »,
qui veut dire « habitude »,
« mauvaise habitude ».
« Madame,
madame, s’il vous plaît,
vous pourriez me donner un peu
de fauteuil moelleux s’il vous plaît ?
Madame,
s’il vous plaît. »
« Monsieur, monsieur,
s’il vous plaît, s’il vous plaît.
Après, promis, j’arrête ! »
(Applaudissements)